Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Canadian comedy film
called “Starbuck”. Watch out and take care!
David Wozniak is a young man living
in Quebec, Canada. He makes money by
frequently donating sperm to the LaFrance
clinic. At the beginning of the movie,
he is in between one of his visits to the sperm
bank, pleasuring himself to pictures of women
in a magazine. The scene shifts Twenty-three years
later, in 2011. David is now a middle-aged man but
he still doesn’t have a definite job. He is woken
up by thugs whom he owes eighty thousand dollars.
They dump him into the bathtub, threatening him to
return their money. Following the unusual morning,
he goes to his parents’ butcher shop where he
works as a delivery man. He is forty-five minutes
late and is yelled at for taking the delivery
truck home again. The workers in the shop,
along with his father, are on a football team
and are about to take a team picture the next
day. David was told to pick up the jerseys for
the pictures three weeks ago but he still hasn’t
gotten it. Everyone is tired of him for not
doing as told even when the job is simple.
After work, he rushes to the clothing store but
the owner happens to be closing it right then.
He quickly parks his truck in the middle of the
road and begs the owner to give him the jerseys.
The man does it out of sympathy but David
gets a parking ticket in the process.
Following that, he visits several banks to
ask for a loan to pay off his debts. However,
he doesn’t have the required collateral for them
to pass the loan. After facing several rejections,
he returns home and tells his co-worker on the
phone that he has received the jerseys. The person
on the other end is skeptical, knowing that David
isn’t reliable. Outside, his truck is taken away
by the traffic police because he received too many
parking tickets. The jerseys were still in the
truck which means the team has to take pictures
without them. Everyone is disappointed in David,
although they are used to his behavior.
After that, David goes to his girlfriend Valérie’s
house. She is a police officer and is way more
financially independent than David. He hasn’t
spoken to her in a few days which Valérie is upset
about. As David tries to explain himself, she
reveals that she is pregnant. David is taken aback
by the revelation. He cannot tell if he likes the
news or not. Valérie senses that he is hesitant
and claims that she is going to keep the child no
matter what. Following the interaction, David goes
to meet his friend, The Lawyer. The lawyer has
four kids, all of whom refuse to listen to him.
He has been troubled by fatherhood and suggests
David to not have children ever in his life.
David, however, wants to be a father, he is only
confused if this is the right time for him. The
very next morning, he goes to Valérie’s work and
declares to her that he is ready to be a father to
their child. On reaching home, he meets a man in
a suit who introduces himself as Chamberlan.
He is the lawyer for the clinic that David used
to donate sperm to. Between 1988 and
1990, David donated sperm to the bank
under the name “Starbuck”. He made over
six hundred and ninety-three donations
over the period of twenty-three months. Because of
some kind of error, the company provided all its
clients with David’s sperms and as a result, he
has fathered five hundred thirty-three children.
Out of them, one hundred and forty-two want to
know his identity. But, before every donation,
David had signed a confidentiality contract,
according to which, the clinic isn’t allowed
to share his personal information. Hence,
the hundred and forty-two children who want
to get to know their father have sued the
company and their confidentiality clause so
they would be given the information about
David. Hearing all this, David freaks out
and repeatedly says that he is not Starbuck.
After the encounter, he goes to meet his friend,
the lawyer, and tells him about the matter. The
lawyer wants him to file a countersuit against
the clinic and make some money but David refuses
to do so. He notes down all the information about
the sperm donation procedure and hands David an
envelope with information about all his children.
The next morning, David decides to take a look
at a paper inside the envelope out of curiosity.
The paper he pulls out has information about
a star football player, Ricardo Donatelli.
David realizes that he is the father of one
of his favorite players and rushes to tell the
lawyer. They go to Ricardo’s game and cheer for
him. Now that David knows the player is his son,
he is proud of his genes. At first, he had
decided that he won’t get involved with his
children’s lives but curiosity gets the best
of him. The next day pulls out a second paper
and gets to know about Étienne, his son who works
at a restaurant. David goes to the said restaurant
and finds Étienne arguing with someone on the
phone. It turns out that he is a struggling actor
who has just missed an opportunity to audition
for a huge role because he is working.
David offers to handle the place for him while
he goes to the audition. Étienne believes he is
a robber who is looking for a tactic to rob their
shop. But when offered the delivery truck to go
to the audition, he agrees. A while later,
the restaurant’s owner arrives at the place
and tells David he will fire Étienne. Hours pass
when Étienne finally returns and says that he
got the part. David is glad that he was able to
make a difference in his son’s life. At night,
he brings out the third paper and finds out about
his daughter Julie. He goes to her place as a
pizza delivery guy and finds her on the phone,
yelling at someone. While he is still in the
house, she locks herself in a room and overdoses
on a drug. David quickly gets her to the hospital.
The next day, Julie is sent to a rehabilitation
center where people assume he is her father.
Julie doesn’t reveal the truth because she wants
David to sign the release papers as her father
so she can be let free. David consults with the
doctor and tries to convince Julie to stay at
rehab. But the girl promises that she will be
better outside because she just got her dream
job yesterday and she doesn’t want to lose
it. At last, David decides to release her.
The next morning he goes to her workplace and
sees she has started the job as she had promised.
On returning home, he pins the papers with his
children’s information to the wall and goes to
meet them one by one. Some of them have grown
to be nail technicians, musicians, lifeguards,
tour guides, and so on. He meets them all and
goes out of his way to help them if they need it.
One day, Valérie visits him at the shop and
asks him to come to the doctor’s with her.
After the doctor’s appointment, they
go to a park and watch children play.
Valérie is scared about the pregnancy and
thinks she is not ready to be a mother. David,
on the other hand, promises to be the best father
and comforts her. The next day, he finds out that
one of his children named Raphael is disabled. He
goes to the home of disabled people and nervously
talks to his son. Raphael realizes that someone
is around but he is unable to talk or respond
because of his disability. David spends the day
talking to him, even though the kid cannot reply.
He also feeds Raphael during lunch break.
The next day, while following his other son,
David ends up at a meeting organized by all
the children who were born because of Starbuck.
Seeing all of his offspring in a place overwhelms
David and he stands up involuntarily.
He is suddenly handed a microphone and asked
to speak. David tells them that he loves them
and gives a heartfelt speech about all of them
being siblings. After the program, he meets Julia,
Étienne, and other children who he has helped.
To hide his identity, he pretends to be Raphael’s
adoptive father. The children have formed
a community of a sort and have started to
socialize with each other as half-siblings. When
David returns home that day, he is again dumped
into the bathtub by the thugs to whom he owes
money. At night, one of his sons, Antonie who
has somehow found out about his identity comes to
his house. He says that he doesn’t want to reveal
David’s identity to the people and is only looking
to spend a few days with his biological father.
David agrees to let him stay at the house. He and
Valérie go to his parents’ house for dinner that
day. As the table erupts into friendly chatter,
David’s father tells them about the time David
bought them tickets to Italy. It turns out that
his parents hadn’t had a chance to go on their
honeymoon so David used all the money that he
collected from donating sperm to take them on
vacation. Although no one knows where he got
the money from, they praise his thoughtfulness.
Valérie looks at David differently after finding
out what he had done for his family. Then,
David and Antonie go to football practice together
and enjoy a father-son day. The day goes well
until David mentions that he has to tend to his
“real” family now that Valérie is pregnant.
The following day, David’s children organize a
picnic. They sing, dance, eat together, and have a
lot of fun as siblings. However, the day after the
event, the story of Starbuck catches the media’s
attention. Although the children didn’t mean to
make Starbuck look bad, the media paints him as a
pervert who used his sexuality to make money. When
David asks Valérie what she thinks about Starbuck,
she claims that he is similar to a prostitute.
The two get into an argument about the matter.
One day, before a football practice,
the team is talking about Starbuck.
All of David’s teammates think he is a creep
and a pervert. His brother asks him if he has
ever donated but David denies having done anything
like that. The conversation gets heated when they
assume he is lying. David almost attacks his
brother and has to be stopped by the others.
That evening, he is informed that the thugs whom
he owes money threatened his father and tried to
drown him in the bathtub. If he doesn’t pay off
the debts soon, his entire family will suffer.
Hence, David goes to the lawyer and says he
will file a countersuit against the clinic
for using his sperms unethically. He hopes that
after winning the lawsuit the clinic will provide
him monetary compensation. The lawyer is happy
to have finally gotten a big case that will bring
him fame if he wins. For the next few days,
they work very hard to create a strong case.
The night before the ruling, they play football
in the pouring rain to relieve stress. The
judge finally announces that Starbuck is entirely
entitled to his anonymity which means the children
will not get to see their biological father
unless he wants to show himself deliberately.
David is also entitled to receive a total of two
hundred thousand dollars for damages and interest.
David celebrates the win from his house while the
lawyer is swarmed by reporters, congratulating
him for the win. He expresses his gratitude to his
mother, kids, and accidentally says he is thankful
to David as well. When the reporters ask him
who David is, he claims he is his boyfriend.
The children are also interviewed about their
thoughts and opinions on Starbuck. They claim that
although they wanted to see their father, they
understand if he wants to keep living his life
normally. They also declare that Starbuck is not a
freak or a pervert that the media portrays him to
be. In fact, the children think that he is a nice
man who gave them life and a chance to be happy.
David watches the interview, regretting that he
cannot be a father to all his biological children.
He wants to meet them as their dad but is scared
that he won’t get the compensation money if he
does so. He meets the lawyer who confirms
that coming out as Starbuck is a great risk.
On returning home that day, David finds his
father waiting in the kitchen. As they chat,
David tells him that he is Starbuck. Unlike what
he has expected, his father isn’t disappointed or
sad. In fact, he advises David to tell
everyone the truth. He also hands his
son eighty thousand dollars as his part of the
inheritance from the butcher shop. Now that David
has enough money to pay off his debts, he emails
all his children about his true identity.
That night, Valérie goes into premature labor and
gives birth to a healthy baby boy. David’s father,
brothers, along with many of his children come to
the hospital to congratulate him. They embrace in
a big group hug. David tells Valérie about him
being Starbuck. She freaks out initially but
eventually accepts him as he is. The baby gets
numerous presents from all his half-siblings.
In the end, we see David and the
children in a subway, supporting one
of their brothers who is a singer.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.